in most european countries highway tolls
are common drivers can only take their
car on the highway if they pay the toll
but driving on germany's famed autobahns
is still free at least for the time
being
most neighboring countries have long
been charging drivers for road use
some impose a levy according to distance
traveled on the highway
others make drivers buy a pass
tolls may now be imposed in germany too
even on foreign registered cars what do
germans think about this proposal from
bavaria's conservative christian social
union
i'm for it absolutely
i'm opposed at least for making german
drivers pay for the deutsche
no they've squeezed us enough already
it's been pretty big i support a toll
for cars
because you have to pay tolls everywhere
else
if they drop the vehicle tax then tolls
for private cars would be fine
more than half of the germans surveyed
said they would favor highway tolls if
they had to pay less taxes only 39
percent said they would oppose the levy
but the germans are clear about one
thing a new highway toll should be
imposed fairly meaning those who drive
most should pay most as well